this one business owner I sat with I
going to their house it's right after 9
11.
and they said can you tell us about your
background I said sure I'm born and
raised in Iran out of all this stuff and
I said now I'm on Morgan's standing
managing money and you know helping our
families and she says look we don't mind
doing business with anybody from Morgan
Stanley but we would like it to be
somebody else with a background that we
can relate to quite frankly after what
happened with the 911 we feel a little
bit uncomfortable doing business with
somebody from the Middle East now in
that situation I can say how dare you
say that and go cry and complain about
it I said totally understand left
brought back my partner they met they
did business we split commission we were
happy we were gone moral the story is I
don't care who you are if you're a white
black Asian middle eastern tall short
fat skinny educated Not educated you got
to build you don't have a beard you have
a mustache you don't have a mustache
everyone's getting judged whether you
like it or not and and the reason why
this is a topic I'm bringing up is
because as much as everyone's judging us
we're also judging people so if you get
to judge others why can't judge you and
I so the challenge is how we react to it
I'm Dave Rubin and joining me today is
the founder and CEO of valutainment host
of the pbd podcast and author of your
next five moves Master the art of
business strategy Patrick Bet David
finally welcome to the Reuben report
it's great to be on good to see you my
friend uh we are both relatively new
Floridians so I feel we should start
there do you have anything you want to
tell the people about life in Florida
I I got to tell you I lived in L.A 20
some years minus the time in the
military I lived five years in Dallas
Texas which was fantastic I kept one of
my companies there but then Florida if
California and Texas could make a baby
did you get the lifestyle and you get
the taxes they kind of leave you alone
so uh we're in love living in Florida so
you moved the company for what was it
five years in Dallas and then what
caused you to leave Texas because Texas
is pretty good you ain't paying the
taxes there it's a nice lifestyle over
there was it purely weather and uh
tropical leave related yeah that's a
good question so for me we were at a
point where we outgrew the headquarters
and valuetainment and the insurance
company were in the same headquarter the
same office and then it was either I'm
gonna sign a lease of a few years with
by timing in Dallas and kind of move
them to a different building or if I'm
moving that's the time to make the move
so at the time uh when this decision was
being made it was at the beginning of
covid and my wife and I we were looking
at New York because if we're running a
media company Media Company you got to
be in a place where you can recruit
Executives from the media company you
can recruit talent to want to live there
so we said Greenwich New York great it's
right there's the mecca you can compete
the Market's available we looked at
Tennessee because the state taxes
and then we looked at potentially going
back to Newport Beach California because
you know media again there but covet
happened everything kind of moved away
from there we always go to Florida and
then uh I knew value timid and the media
company would be a lot easier to recruit
people to South Florida than any of the
other locations so lifestyle was there I
got four kids now ten and eight a six
and my daughter just turned one so we
got a family that's a younger startup
family we got to be in a place that
Sports education all of that combined
together finally we said South Florida's
place to go and then obviously the rest
is history and I have seen the video of
the house on YouTube and uh it's not bad
let's just say it's not bad
two-bedroom condo you know it's a very
nice place we like it we're very happy
with it yeah two two bedroom condo might
be under the house that you're rocking
over there on the water in Fort Lauder
absolutely beautiful so I know my
audience all knows you from uh from the
business side of things and mostly from
the podcast side of things and we'll get
into some of that stuff uh but can you
just tell people who don't know your bio
a little bit about growing up in Iran
and just some of the some of the who how
you got to where you are kind of stuff
well born and raised in Iran lived there
in uh for 10 years in Tehran Iran During
the Revolution with the Shah that was
born October 1878 four months later he
was an exile they kicked him out then
Romani showed up then the military was
in shambles because two thousand of his
leaders were reporting to the shop who
many got rid of them Saddam saw that as
an opportunity he attacked half a
million people got killed six weeks
after hominy dies this is around July
15th of 89 we escape I go to Germany
with my mom and my sister we lived at a
refugee camp for a year and a half and
then from Germany we came to the states
I went to Glendale California right
after high school I joined the army went
to the 101st Airborne Division air
assault and got out of the army I wanted
to be a bodybuilder I was going to be
the next Mr Olympia you know Arnold
Schwarzenegger I was gonna win Mr
Olympia going to be an actor Mary
Kennedy and then one day run for
governor but then I met a girl named
John beer who worked at Morgan Stanley
Dean Witter she told me about Morgan
Stanley Dean whether I was 21 and she
said this is how I make a living it's a
great industry I started working at
Morgan Stanley Dean with her a day
before 9 11 and then I stayed in the
industry seven and a half years later I
was in Transamerica I was a year at the
Morgan seven and a half years
Transamerica and then October of 09
started my own insurance company PHP we
grew that from 66 agents to 20 000 plus
agents 150 offices Nationwide and then
accidentally started a YouTube channel
that turned into a media company
valuetainment and then obviously the
rest is history so I love how you say
that all with just such ease I mean I
know you've told that story there's a
million stories within that story I know
you've said it a million times before
but the reason I wanted you to say it
was because you are as much as anyone I
think I've ever had on the show the
living breathing example of what the
American dream is now how could that
possibly be you are a brown-skinned
immigrant I thought that this is the
most racist place I thought we hate
people from the Middle East
etc etc how do you do it
you know the power of levity let me give
you an idea what I mean by the power of
levity and the power of not taking
everything personally and crying about
it so I'm in the uh uh in the Army and
one time one of these uh uh soldiers
private I'm in boot camp with these guys
and they say so where are you from I
said I'm from Iran says what do you mean
you're from Iran I sit down from Iran so
how are you in the military you know
aren't you are you a U.S citizen I said
no I got a green card how do you get
into the military as a you know Iranian
Citizen and you're now in our army I
said can you guys keep a secret they
said yeah what's up I said honestly I'm
kind of like an underground spy
operation right now I'm trying to think
and by the way these guys believed it
and it was spent to the point where my
sergeant had to come and talk to me
about it when we laughed about it but
obviously there's some levity to it yeah
I remember going to Alabama one time and
the waiter at Waffle House were on the
way to Panama City Florida to party for
like at Club La Villa and this Panama
City waiters just looking at me angled
and he's like I've never seen a nose
like that before I said this is what you
call a legit qualified nose from the
Middle East you guys don't have stuff
like this in America we have it in Iran
I've never met an iranium before I said
I'm an Iranian anyways then I go and I
start working on Morgan Stanley it's a
very interesting story what happens all
the time I got into the LDS Market
clients who were LDS and it's a very
good Market to get into you know when
you're managing money you're going to
get into different kind of markets Car
Wash owners doctors one of the markets I
got into was LDS and as one business
owner I said with I going to their house
it's right after 9 11.
and they said can you tell us about your
background I said sure I'm born and
raised in Iran out of all this stuff and
I said now I'm on Morgan's standing
managing money and you know helping our
families and she says look we don't mind
doing business with anybody from Morgan
Stanley but we would like it to be
somebody else with a background that we
can relate to quite frankly after what
happened with the 911 we feel a little
bit uncomfortable doing business with
somebody from the Middle East now in
that situation I can say how dare you
say that and go cry and complain about
it I said totally understand left
brought back my partner they met they
did business we split commission we were
happy we were gone moral the story is I
don't care who you are if you're a white
black Asian middle eastern tall short
fat skinny educated Not educated you got
to build you don't have a beard you have
a mustache you don't have a mustache
everyone's getting judged whether you
like it or not and and the reason why
this is a topic I'm bringing up is
because as much as everyone's judging us
we're also judging people so if you get
to judge others why can't judge you and
I so the challenge is how we react to it
you can go and think like you're a
victim I cannot believe what he said or
you can go prove him wrong maybe that
person was right maybe they didn't make
the right decision and then maybe 20
years later they're sending their
husband and wife and saying babe
that was the guy that we said no to and
look at him now look how successful he
is but either way someone's gonna be
right so when you're saying the whole
American Dream success story look I'll
tell you something about right now
the time we're in right now there is two
camps there's the camps that are like
well listen don't worry it's just not a
big deal it's going to be a small Market
correction you know like the Dave Ramsey
Camp real estate's not going to really
take because look at the inventory it's
not really that high maybe Dave Ramsey's
right maybe he's not but it's gonna be
all right don't worry about it and then
there's the camp that's going to be like
listen I think it's a [ __ ] show I think
I better pay attention to what's going
on what do you mean you know inventory
is going up interest rates are going up
inflation has gone up gas prices are
going up Fourth of July cost me 11 more
this year than it did last year making a
million dollars two years ago and you
make it today it's like making 600 000
today just two years later a hundred
thousand dollars two years ago sixty
thousand dollars but at the same time
that can either produce a lot of fear
for you and you don't move it you don't
do anything or you can look at this
marketplace where fear is high you just
have to know the American dream of the
next great stories are burned you know
born during times of Crisis they the
American dream is alive anybody and
everybody can go out there and have
their dreams become a reality whatever
that may be but it will take a lot of
effort and you not taking things
personally if you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of non-stop
yelling check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlist all right over here and
to get notified of all future videos be
sure to subscribe and click the
notification Bell